we have a really packed program today so
I'm gonna do everybody a favor and not
spend five minutes talking about how
it's a packed program and just get into
the substance they're now trying to ban
abortion nationally
um I told you this would happen it
wasn't just me it's not a pat on the
back it was very obvious and many of us
were predicting after the Supreme Court
made a decision which overturned Roe v
Wade overturning the fundamental right
to an abortion in most cases for uh in
the United States we had this prediction
that this was only the beginning now why
was it such an obvious prediction well
you don't get your biggest win and then
stop I mean you know even Michael Jordan
won three championships before he
temporarily retired and then came back
and then won three more would have been
weird to just win that first one and
then say see everybody later uh on the
one hand there were the sort of more
obvious predictions well once you
overturned the right to an abortion
the next thing is you try to ban it out
right you go beyond just overturning it
as of right you say let's make this
illegal and then beyond that it's maybe
they'll try to overturn the gay marriage
decision from 2015 and on the far end
it's well do they want to try to
overturn interracial marriage much more
far-fetched but the point is you don't
stop after your biggest Victory and now
indeed Lindsey Graham has introduced a
nationwide abortion ban just weeks after
he said well that's something that
should be left up to the states Lindsey
Graham is a hypocrite of course but
that's not really what this is about
this is really about the obvious
predictability that this is something
they were going to try to do as Rolling
Stone writes Lindsey Graham introduced a
federal abortion ban Tuesday weeks after
declaring it's an issue that should be
left to the states I think we should
have a law at the federal level says
Lindsay that would say that after 15
weeks no abortion on demand now on
demand is another one of these
propaganda terms what does it mean on
demand it's like you could just add it
to anything well I don't know what what
about uh knee replacement on demand
we're talking about the exact same
process by which you consult with a
doctor and then a decision is made and a
procedure is either done or not done at
the agreement of the doctor and the
patient on demand is another one of
these phrases that's just meant to make
things seem completely out of control
anyway uh as Rolling Stone writes Graham
wants to overrule the right of states to
set their own abortion laws despite
having said on several occasions it
should actually be decided by States not
the federal government just last month
he said quote I think States should
decide the issue of marriage and States
should decide the issue of abortion so
they're trying to do it
um talking points memo article
Republicans move to ban abortion
Nationwide and it also this a particular
article goes on to talk about the bigger
picture strategy and there is some risk
to this strategy and this is kind of
where I want to focus in because we we
knew they were going to do this and how
they're going to do it is obvious but
okay if I it's all totally predictable
when you look at polling abortion being
legal in most cases is quite popular
with Americans in fact Americans are
very divided about so many different
issues but abortion being legal in most
cases is one of the issues on which
Americans are relatively United you see
significantly more than 60 support for
that and so there's a risk and we'll see
in November whether that risk ends up
damaging Republicans there's a risk that
if you focus too much on Banning and
preventing abortion that you will lose
support and that you will lose elections
so there is a political risk here for
sure when you are loudly running against
something that is popular nationally
there's a couple of possibilities now
one possibility and this is very dark
and I hope that this isn't the case is
if Republicans are so sure
that now they've got it successfully
rigged because remember in 2020 they
tried to steal it but they failed while
accusing the left of trying to steal it
which of course the left wasn't doing
if for 2022 and 2024 they're feeling
more confident in their ability to take
elections that the will of the people
doesn't actually show them winning then
they could say well but we we know how
to win regardless of what people want so
let's go ahead and try to ban abortion
that's one possibility
the other possibility is that this is a
terrible miscalculation because because
they correctly recognize that being
against abortion is still a great way to
raise money from certain groups but it
has become decoupled from support out in
the general population so they're
interested they see oh if we if we do
this if we try to ban abortion these
moneyed groups will give us a ton of
money but we're going to lose a lot of
the people so it could be a
miscalculation and then the third one
which I don't think there's really
evidence for is there intentionally
sabotaging themselves uh I mean I'm
including it in the list but it doesn't
seem particularly likely that that's
what's going on and then the the fourth
possibility also is they just disagree
with the polling they might just say we
don't agree that two-thirds of Americans
as every poll shows believe abortion
should be legal in most cases we think
the polling is wrong and we think this
is a winning Way Forward now whether
they will even get a vote on this
remains a question Mitch McConnell was
asked about it yesterday didn't really
answer
so we're going to continue following it
but not a surprise to anybody who's been
paying attention after overturning Roe v
Wade the next step is let's see about a
federal ban on abortion we'll see where
it gets them